[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission où
on parle cuisine agriculture écologie
politique et on va en parler avec le
confinement beaucoup on veut parler des
bonnes et des mauvaises recettes pour
passer ce confinement vous le voyez sur
ce plateau
nous sommes masqué c'est le protocole
arrêté par l'assemblée nationale parce
que notre plateau est petit mais on va
quand même pouvoir déguster tous ces
plats alors avec moi pour présenter
cette émission jean pierre montaner
bonjour gentillet jour brigitte bonjour
patrick mignola je te rejoins patrick
mignola vous êtes président du groupe
modem et démocrate apparenté vice
présidente du modem un pur produit
centriste à 21 ans vous êtes déjà
président national du mouvement des
jeunes républicains composante de l'udf
vous devenez ensuite membres des
cabinets ministériels de françois
léotard françois bayrou michel mercier
mais vous êtes aussi un produit du
terroir vous le natif de chambéry
vous avez été maire de la ravoire une
petite commune de savoie à la savoie qui
ne semble pourtant pas avoir tellement
inspiré le menu du jour jean pierre non
au menu de l'oeuf dans tous ses états
avec des oeufs nous laisse sécher la
poutargue avec des tagliatelles et on
dessert c'est la poule cette fois qui
s'y colle avec des oeufs à la neige mais
attention on verra pourquoi sans caramel
dans les pieds dans le plat les
restaurateurs ont du pain sur la planche
obligé de fermer boutique il développe
le click and collect je commande et
j'emporte vous entendrez le patron de
chez françoise qui nous fournit les
plats chaque semaine et encore pendant
le confinement est donc dessous des
plats nous poserons la question est ce
possible d'acheter dans l'alimentaire
100% français pas si simple en raison de
la prolifération des ti cats pas
toujours très claires
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidences patrick mignola
votre alliance avec la république en
marche et le modem à votre parti pour
l'édile hâtif de 2017 a laissé des
traces lorsque vous êtes à table
ça donne en fait durant même temps en
même temps des oeufs et des pâtes à la
poutargue qui sont désormais asséchées
et en même temps des heures cette fois
c'est la poule
ouf des oeufs olé comment dit désolé oui
d eux la neige les yeux la neige même
des yeux la neige mais sans caramel
alors brigitte l'a dit ah vous êtes
savoyard comment un savoyard qui baigne
dans les fromages peut s'intéresser à la
poutargue d'abord est ce que vous dites
poutargue ou boutin jeudi bottarga
boutargue à mais parce que là
l'italienne parce que la savoie est
quand même frontalière avec l'italie et
que et que j'aime mes plats savoyard la
tome des bauges j'aime le beaufort
j'aime le reblochon
et puis je crois que beaucoup de gens
aiment ces plats en france mais j'aime
aussi faire trois heures de voiture et
me retrouve en italie et en quelques
jours avoir le sentiment que le temps a
été suspendu pendant plusieurs semaines
dit tout ce que c'est un petit peu parce
que tout le monde ne connaît pas ce que
c'est que la poutargue ou la boutargue a
comme vous dites alors ce sont des oeufs
de poissons de mule qui sont séchées et
que ensuite on peut utiliser en le rap
en a il vaut mieux être plusieurs à
table c'est bien qu'on soit 3
aujourd'hui puisque ça se conserve très
mal ça permet d'avoir un plat
complètement brut parce que vous faites
des pâtes
vous mettez un trait d'huile d'olive du
sel du poivre et vous rappellent un peu
de poutargue et c'est fait et ça vous
l'avez découvert à quel âge la boutade
c'est pas un puits sans fond ça fait pas
de nom ça fait pas très longtemps c'est
justement en allant en italie ou où j'ai
constaté un jour je devais être à
bologne elle et j'ai vu un serveur
regarder avec admiration un client qui
avait commandé les spaghettis labo
targue pourtant bologne c'est pas la
terre de la poutargue c'est vrai on en
mange plutôt en sicile en sardaigne
un peu dans le golfe de gênes
oui mais en fait en italie contrairement
à ce qu'on pense le l'italie utilise
énormément les produits de la mer même à
l'intérieur et c'est vrai que essayé
aller dans un restaurant italien
même quand c'est pas en italie et vous
comment des spaghettis la bouteille là
on va vous regarder en disant ça je vois
la liste voilà quelqu'un qui sait ce que
c'est manger des pâtes bon alors c'est
chez françoise on l'a dit qu'ils nous
fournissent et pl je vous tends ce plat
la merci beaucoup
donc ce sont des tagliatelles en fait
alors on peut enlever le masque pour
goûter le plat merci bockel on peut
faire donc je vous encourage à le faire
et puis ce sont des tagliatelles 1 ce ne
sont pas des spaghettis et on voit la
boutargue sur le dessus en fait ça se
présente comme cela alors là elle est
par ap
là les dents fines lamelles mais
monsieur mignot a parlé de la rapée mais
aussi on peut la couper en fines
lamelles
ce qu'il faut aussi dire brigitte c'est
que c'est un plat très clivant patrick
mignot 1 disait il vaut mieux être
nombreux à table et souvent c'est pas
facile de trouver une communauté de 6,8
qui est prête à partager de la poutre
est prononcée trio des traits boissons
fort ça une jolie couleur il ya une
harmonie des couleurs l'annoncent
plaquer un peu chez lui je vous confirme
que quand j'en fais à la maison de toute
façon je me fais très vite sermonné par
mon épouse en la laissant au frigo que
c'est en plus à un goût assez fort qui
donne du goût et tout le reste
effectivement elle est parfois
conditionné vous l'avais dit dans un
bloc de cir qui permet 2001 mais parfois
les sens ce bloc de cire donc ça dépend
un peu ça peut être très chère brigitte
caviar de le caviar de la méditerranée
il ya une surpêche
alors vous avez aussi des poutargue de
ton par exemple au maroc ou en
mauritanie ont fait on prend plutôt de
tomber c'est moins faim que les yeux de
mulets et un petit corps et qu'on met un
peu un peu vrai un public c'est un peu
de métier
les français savent en faire les
martégaux faisait beaucoup de poutargue
de il ya quelques siècles
donc on a aussi la france est une terre
de poutargue ses romans est-ce que c'est
à votre exceptionnel patrick mignola ce
très bon et très bon c'est très bon
c'est presque aussi bon que quand je le
fais moi-même non pardon mais vous êtes
très très gourmand très jour mais vous
aimez cuisiner
oui j'aime beaucoup cuisiner mais en
fait j'avais un grand père qui était
cuisinier donc j'ai toujours beaucoup
cuisiner vous avez traîné dans ses rangs
près des fourneaux
ah oui c'est ça en fait ils étaient
pêcheurs au bord du lac du bourget donc
tous les matins ils partaient récupère
et tente où les écrevisses tantôt les
grenouilles tantôt les brochets et je le
regardais faire il ne m'est jamais
appris en tant que tel à faire à manger
donc donc je le fais volontiers la
maison je fais des choses très simples
mais mon épouse aime pas beaucoup
cuisiner
alors quelle cuisine très bien je
cuisine finalement moins bien qu'elle
m'aimait je cuisine à chaque voilà vous
aimez faire le marché
vous allez le dock samedi matin les
moches mètres et j'ai même faire le
marché et le supermarché monsieur je
suis un flâneur de supermarchés alors
ils ont peut plus le faire en période de
kobe tu parce qu'au contraire faut il
passer le moins longtemps possible mais
j'aime bien les découvrir les produits
nouveaux ce qui est sorti alors c'est
même un peu bizarre que mais mes yeux je
vous créez un peu différente
en fait ce que je fais principalement en
matière de d'alimentation c'est
accommoder les restes
ah ça c'est une bonne technique ça c'est
formidable moi j'aime j'adore vous
frigo et essayer d'inventer quelque
chose quand on les enfants à la maison
parce qu'elle souvent des plats à peu
commencé à droite et à gauche voilà est
donc plutôt que laisser gaspillé alors
donné je me pique et astuces
l'accommoder spectateurs comment
accommoder trois bouts de pommes de
terre à bout de fromage et à les
courgettes bombe le la lors alors vous
complète ou alors vous couper tout comme
il faut d'abord vous les faites cuire
pas ensemble le secret quand même pour
que ce soit bon il faut quand même que
la cuisson se fait séparément
voilà pour le coup vous pouvez casser un
oeuf dessus si vous voulez vraiment
faire un truc vous faites vous faites
vous faites tout cuire séparément mettez
ça dans un plat allez quelques quelques
morceaux de beurre et puis et puis vous
rappellez dernier morceau de fromage que
vous avez dans le frigo dessus vous
mettez ça au four bon avec avec deux
tranches de saucisson ce sera parfait
les enfants se régaleront
vous m'avez l'air assez incollables on
va passer au quiz 1 dans cette émission
alors vous êtes originaire de savoie
on l'a déjà vu en préambule sans doute
incollable sur vos fromages mais en tant
qu'ancien conseiller régional auvergne
rhône-alpes
dites-moi laquelle de ses pattes ne fait
pas partie de cette région
alors le salaire sont à en b le saint
marcellin en c'est la tome des bauges et
hand et le crottin de chavignol monsieur
le trop-plein de cheminots la salers et
de formidables fromageot berne alors on
va continuer voilà le seul marcellin le
saint marcellin elle département ça se
lisait tout près de chez moi
et la tome des bauges et la tome des
bauges c'est dans ma circonstances était
la dernière à ob qu'on a obtenus dans la
région aspects des citations
alors vous savez que la première aoc qui
avait été fait c'est celle du beaufort
savoie partout en france
la première session des savoyards qui
ont inventé l'appellation d'origine
contrôlée l'appellation d'origine
contrôlée pour protéger le beaufort
c'est comme ça que ce terroir du
beaufortain a été sauvé le beaufortain
ces quatre communes
quatre barrages et quatre mille vaches
schématiquement on a reconnu dans le
monde entier
exactement et une grande personnalité
qui fréquentaient ce territoire et qui
avait contribué à l'époque et que
monsieur viallet a inventé la hausse et
c'était hubert beuve méry ah oui le
fondateur du monde qui s'y retirait un
mois
chaque été dans une maison sans eau sans
électricité sans assainissement et c'est
ainsi que qu'ils réfléchissaient et il a
permis aussi aux savoyards de réfléchir
avec lui pour arriver à faire désosser
vous êtes très très fort deuxième couac
pour voir si vous vous en sortez aussi
bien alors laquelle de ces légendes
urbaines sur le creuset petites pattes
savoyarde est fausse alors hein ça vient
du patois savoyard cros et qui signifie
petit b ça vient de creuser village du
forez qui a provisionné la savoie en
farine de sarrasin
c'est ça vient du latin un cru qui veut
dire croix des ça vient du nom du
docteur croisa qui prescrivaient d
creusé à ses patients mais je faisais
vraiment l'un des chercheurs
vous êtes creuser la tête mais c'est le
ccc à la bonne réponse derrick rose a
une qui fausse parce que très sûr alors
après il faudrait la fosse ce sont des
légendes qui sont à mes sur les légendes
locales et des légendes urbaines un
deuxième qui est complètement fou là
cela c'est vrai c'est le sait le patois
la deuxième je la vois pas bien dur de
creuser village du forez qui
approvisionnait la savoie en farine de
sarrasin est ce que est ce que dans le
forez ont fait du sarrasin je ne suis
pas sûr du tout moi voilà c'est arrivé
donc temps que c'est bien ça c'était
faux d'accord bah oui parce que parce
que non la farine de sarrasin
ils font fait beaucoup de choses dans le
forez mais on fait pas de farine même
bien j'avoue des sur dix pour les deux
les deux quiz alors on a on a dit que
quand vous alliez déjeuner chez vos
collègues du modem vous avez ils ont un
peu vendu la mèche au lieu d'apporter
des fleurs vous apportiez volontiers
vous du fromages de savoie
et puis du bon vin vous êtes un peu le
spécialiste arriver quand les gens je
trouve ça sympa d'abord se fait
connaître le lait fromages chez avaya en
plus c'est un beau cadeau parce que
parce que quand vous essayez de trouver
du beaufort aparis vaut plutôt autour de
40 euros le kilo alors que j'arrive à
trouver des très belles me le numéro
sancerre celles qui sont les plus fruité
autour de 20,22 euros en savoie donc
cela permet d'avoir un peu plus voilà je
suis là mon explication sur la meule
sans ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire en
fait quand vous faites du beaufort c'est
que c'est depuis les techniques
traditionnelles même si aujourd'hui on a
mis un peu plus de technologie en fait
vous avez des grandes cuves dans
lesquels vous vous mettez le lait et
puis progressivement bas vous sortez le
lait pour en faire des fromages dont qui
sont des meules à peu près de 2,7
d'ailleurs et puis on ne part qu on fait
sans fromage et il vaut toujours mieux
taper dans la moule la meule numéro 100
parce que c'est celle qui au fond de la
cuve et donc c'est celle chorale
travailler qu'on va récupérer tous les
goûts qu'ont vécu un peu plus longtemps
dans la cuve et c'est là que vous avez
les goûts de de fruits de fleurs parce
que le bo ford était offert divers et
bon ciné mais ça c'est c'est un bouffeur
de soins et c'est comme la langue que
des boucles bien sûr mais c'est ask et
sur la meule le numéro 100 si je vais
chez mon fromage et de demain jeudi je
dû s'en aller chercher des ces
étiquettes est vraiment belloche je suis
sûr que votre fromage et qui doit être
très bon koné me le numéro 100 mais en
général les distributeurs en fait les
garde pour les dégustations ou pour les
restaurants d'accord pour qu'on ait
vraiment le volet vraiment le goût alors
mais par contre si vous avez un fromager
à paris qui connaît les meules numéro
100 de beaufort celui-là on lui fera une
médaille d'honneur du travail a alors
raconté nos c'était comment le dimanche
mais chez les mignola quand vous étiez
petit on parlait politique ont dégusté
quoi on parlait pas du tout politique
parce que le mes parents ont toujours
été très inquiet que je fasse de la
politique
j'ai eu envie d'en faire d'eux des tout
petits on mangeait les plaques avaient
été inventées par mon grand-père mon
cher papa qui cuisine est une maman qui
cuisine est beaucoup et très bien
c'était les plats comme mon grand-père
était restaurateur qui avait été un peu
ces places tard alors évidemment c'est
une restauration des années 30 40 et
puis jusqu'aux années 70 c'est ce qu'on
mangeait et donc on mangeait vraiment du
local donc c'était les grenouilles fait
un peu à la persillade le brochet
c'était plutôt la quenelle de brochet
avec un peu les anomalies somme à lyon
la conac brochet voilà exactement mais
mais plus avec les écrevisses du lac
d'accord donc non ne faisait pas
forcément la sauce nantua
quand tu as et l'autre département celle
installée la perche à exister aussi
gérer le bien sûr de la plus tôt la
petite friture ça c'était plutôt la
friture de perche ou pas facile à faire
après quand le quand les perches un peu
plus sont un peu plus grosse pour les
cuisiner au beurre mais c'était plutôt
de la friture de perchaudes le la vraie
perche c'est plutôt le lac léman
d'accord et ça fait le qui fait ce genre
de plats l'aveu lloris au suprême est
quelque chose d'assez formidable donc
assez inspiré de la volaille de bresse
mais comme en savoie on est moins riche
que en bresse d'ailleurs on met pas les
trucs qui vont avec neal et maury mais
médée avec une belle volée youri avec un
bon bouillon de poule 5 du produit déjà
à l'époque ben oui oui pis produits
produits du lac
parce que c'est vrai que quand on parle
de la savoie je sais bien fait
immédiatement on s'imagine les montagnes
la neige les moon boots et la
tartiflette
mais les deux tiers de la savoie c'est
là sa boîte en bas c'est chambéry aix
les bains sur des clichés c'est plutôt
la savoie des lacs
donc on est plutôt un terrain plat et on
s'est plutôt fait plus tout le tour et
voilà plutôt des produits du lac et il
ya ya un poisson qui est absolument
formidable c'est l'omble chevalier
ah oui voilà ça revient à la mode est
une autre histoire font l'ombre le
chevalier parce qu'ils veulent plus
aller chercher des poissons en
atlantique ont méditerranée on se
recentre sur ses à rester unie chien
quand même on connaît pas partout non
mais dans ces restaurants dur il ya
beaucoup de restaurateurs qui ne veulent
plus faire s'approvisionner en
méditerranée et en atlantique à cause de
ce que tu disais des circuits coup
et du coup on va chercher de l'omble
chevalier et puis c'est un poisson de
lacq qui n'a pas trop le goût de vase
parce qu'il peut arriver sur des
brochets que vous ayez cette espèce de
goût de poisson de lacq est un peu
vaseux
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on en fait
plutôt de la cannelle ou de houe de la
terrine mai mais vous avez le sandre
l'omble chevalier déplace tard un jour
je l'avais invité jean-françois kahn à
venir parler de victor hugo en savoie
avec une soirée assez formidable et lui
dit je viens je viens gratuitement je te
demande même pas de me payer l'hôtel la
seule chose que je te demande c'est
d'aller déguster un nombre le chevalier
au bord du lac du bourget est ce qu'un a
beaucoup des souvenirs à table on va
passer à présent à la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé patrick mignola
de réfléchir à un souvenir autour d'un
repas qui mêle effectivement
l'alimentation la nourriture et la
politique vous avez sûrement ça vous qui
avez une longue carrière politique où
vivent d'ailleurs il ya plein de ya
plein de repas qui qui sont indicibles
si on peut pas répéter ce qui s'est dit
si on battait le g1 j'ai le meilleur
souvenir de ma vie à table en table
politique
ce qu'un jour j'ai décidé d'arrêter de
faire la politique moi j'avais été élu
la première fois en 1995 et le président
de la république avait pas le droit de
vote
parce que j'ai toujours aimé ça aidait
des 23 ans voilà j'avais été élu après
je suis devenu conseiller général
conseiller régional j'ai occupé plein de
fonctions et puis en 2009
j'ai décidé de quitter tous mes mandats
et de rester juste maire pour avoir ma
commune avec mes copains et c'était très
bien comme ça et j'ai invité quelqu'un
dont je voulais faire mon successeur est
en fait ma successeur qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait odile que j'ai essayé de
convaincre à la fin du repas je l'avais
pas convaincu de me remplacer au conseil
général
mais en revanche je les ai épousé un an
après et donc c'est probablement le
meilleur souvenir politique parce que ça
a commencé comme un déjeuner politique
et j'ai trouvé la femme de ma vie belle
histoire
bon alors on va continuer on va parler
encore un peu on avait bu un peu aussi
c'est peut-être
comme on est à la télé on dit avec
modération et on avait dégusté un
certain nombre de vins savoyard je vais
faire des découvertes notamment de vin
d'assemblage savoyard à partir de mon 2
à partir de personnes qui sont des très
vieux cépages chaouia et qui était forme
il allait on va continuer à parler un
petit peu de politiques et volonté de
celui de confinement et ses conséquences
je vous propose qu'on passe à la
deuxième partie de cette émission et on
met les pieds dans le plat
alors les français sont confrontés à
leur deuxième confinement mais dès le
premier ils ont un peu changé leurs
habitudes
c'est le cas de claude qui a décidé
d'acheter uniquement des produits frais
et de se mettre aux fourneaux avec
beaucoup de réussite vous allez le voir
c'est un reportage de nathalie gloire ce
week-end donc avec un routis longuement
cuisiné pendant six ou sept heures donc
on va l'accompagner avec un peu de
carottes
braisé claude a décidé de prendre son
temps pour cuisiner ce week-end au menu
ces noix de veau 1 plats qui mijotent
durant de longues heures à des soucis
pour claude préparer des petits plats
c'est devenu nouvel habit qu aujourd'hui
on est on fait quand même beaucoup de
choses maison donc on fait des pâtes ont
fait les raviolis maisons ont fait les
sauces
aussi on élabore et chose pour aller
avec l'ehpad différentes les sauces aux
poissons et social est au matin une
nouvelle passion en et pendant les
longues journées du premier confinement
claude a même cassé sa tirelire en
s'équipant avec des accessoires de
cuisine donc pendant le confinement ont
du coup on a investi on a été obligé
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il
manquait les choses auraient d'abord et
tout ça donc on a investi dans un super
robot rouge
en fait l'idée c'était d'investir dans
quelque chose qui nous permette
d'élaborer tous toutes les recettes
qu'on veut faire un déclic qui a résisté
aux déconfinement au moment du
confinement on a fait beaucoup de choses
ici à la maison
on a fait beaucoup à manger et puis du
coup après mais on a décidé que ce
serait bien aussi de continuer à faire
le maximum
évitez d'acheter du tout près éviter
d'aller acheter un peu n'importe quoi
voilà et son inspiration il la puise à
quelques pas de chez elle au marché de
marine à mosou mais comment ça va ça va
c'est ici qu'elle vient acheter ses
fruits et légumes locaux et trouver de
nouvelles idées de recettes
alors si c'est des produits de saison
puis ça nous oblige à être un peu
créatif en fait parce que moi par
exemple ou romanesco je n'avais pas eu
l'habitude du tout dans une grande
surface vous en avez plein mais vous
passez à côté ou passer vite
moi j'avais pas forcément l'habitude là
l'idée c'est de tenter de manger
différemment donc depuis le confinement
c'est voilà je ne fais plus que mes
courses de cette façon là on est bien
d'accord que j'ai abandonné toutes les
grandes surfaces est ici
claude n'est pas la seule nouvelle
cliente les commandes de pagnes ont
augmenté avec le rester chez vous on a
une prise de conscience pendant le
confinement qui s'est concrétisée sur le
long terme pour certains et avec des
gens qui se rendent compte effectivement
que c'est pas forcément beaucoup plus
cher c'est pas forcément plus difficile
de manger des produits locaux mais il y
en a certains qui nous ont lâchés
juste après le déconfinement donc il
sauve d'une juste nous voir pendant
pendant la période où on était confiné
si certaines personnes ont de nouveau
cédé à la tentation des plats
transformer cloud elle compte bien ne
pas abandonner ces nouvelles habitudes
pour mieux manger surtout aujourd'hui
avec le retour du confinement
alors on l'a vu un patrick mignola sympa
claude qui s'est mis à la cuisine 1
grâce au confinement comme quoi ça à
quelques vertus vous aussi vous avez
revu un peu vos façons de faire la
cuisine façon de faire vos courses avec
le confinement vous n'êtes plus sur des
circuits courts
vous êtes je pense que je l'étais déjà
beaucoup parce que justement il ya une
tare familiale à utiliser plutôt les
produits locaux en circuit court mais
j'ai constaté que les gens avaient pris
l'habitude pendant le premier
confinement et ont conservé cette
habitude d'aller faire travailler les
producteurs locaux notamment les
mariages
ça c'est intéressant parce que vous
l'avez ont constaté dans votre
circonscription oui oui c'est clair
c'est quand même des légumes pour pas le
même mais c'est vrai il allait
directement à la ferme et acheter
directs l'exploitation
voilà et comme ça alors c'était une
occasion de sortie puis finalement c'est
une occasion de sortie très agréable et
c'est des habitudes qui vont perdurer
vous croyez oui oui d'ailleurs ça
perdure est perdu et donc ont donc
continué d'aller chercher les légumes
voilà là où on allait les chercher
et maintenant il ya beaucoup plus de
monde lorsqu'on voit dans le reportage
aussi c'est qu'elle a acheté un robot
ménager on a vu que les magasins lors du
premier confinement ont été dévalisés en
fouet en spatule pauvres est-ce que vous
avez aussi fait la cuisine avec vos
enfants vous pâtissent physique ou qui
s'était par exemple le produit star du
premier confirmant un mais deux j'ai
toujours bien aimé cuisiner que mes
enfants mais mais mais sans robot je
sais pas cuisiner au robot en fait je
suis pas très bon teint fils de
restaurateur la notice de restaurateurs
oui mais maintenant mais maintenant on a
des restaurateurs de grands
restaurateurs qui utilise des robots
quelques ondées vous êtes manon de 2,7
ou mi-robot parce que ça permet de faire
des sauts ça permet de faire les faire
les pâtes à pain ça permet de faire des
glaces très bon c'est pas une injure
donc donc c'est mon avis ça ne nuit pas
l'authenticité de leur travail mais mais
mais je ne fais pas de robot le mon
épouse avait voulu absolument acheter un
robot que vous avez coûter très cher
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on l'utilisait
deux fois s'est classé plus moi qui fais
à manger et que moi je suis réticent aux
robots ça n'a pas marché c'est quoi vos
plats à vos plats signatures à vous
qu'est ce que vous avez fait par exemple
dans le confinement des choses vraiment
simple
le jem faire des lasagnes parce que
parce que les lasagnes en plus on peut
inventer une façon de faire les lasagnes
avec avec tout ce qu'on trouve ce qu'on
a sous la main en produits de saison ça
j'aime plutôt bien faire ça j'aime bien
faire des sauces à partir d'une viande
comment on invente une sauce comment
comment on allonge avec une avec une
crème avec un bouillon
ça permet en plus lorsque l'atr
convaincre les enfants que ça peut être
bon parce qu'ils aiment la sauce à
défaut de la viande ou à défaut
d'apprécier le minime qui vont avec mais
vous trouvez le temps de cuisiner alors
que vous êtes un homme politique on dit
que vous êtes débordé je veux en
confinement ça peut aller mais en tant
normal ou tel temps encore mais il ya
une règle que je me suis fixé c'est de
ne rien faire le dimanche
d'un point de vue professionnel d'un
point de vue professionnel d'un point de
vue politique
ça a été difficile au début tu
l'expliqués parce que le dimanche
souvent ceux des moments d'assemblée
générale on peut se retrouver les
pompiers avec les boulistes combattants
réalité que la démarche est en fait je
me suis fixé cette règle après une
dizaine d'années de mandat est donc le
dimanche il peut être consacrée à faire
à manger ça me fait très plaisir
franchement ça me fait plaisir quand
j'ai eu mes enfants
alors parfois c'est un parfois ces deux
parfois c4 et quand ils sont tous là je
suis au spectacle est en fait et en fait
je le jem leur faire à manger c'est un
plaisir
françois alors le confinement on l'a vu
pour vous ça s'est bien passé mais c'est
aussi parfois la galère on le voit pour
les restaurateurs
il ya plus de services et à plus de
clients ils ont l'interdiction de servir
à table mais bon ils continuent d'ouvrir
quand même leurs portes
mes patrons doivent faire preuve
d'ingéniosité vous allez voir il se
débrouille comme un chef c'est notre
nouvelle rubrique pour continuer à
cuisiner et vendre ses plats le patron
du restaurant chez françoise qui est
situé à deux pas de l'assemblée
nationale et qui est notre partenaire
dans cette émission
eh bien ils s'adaptent claire jouanno
est allé à sa rencontre regardée pascal
mousset patron de chez françoise depuis
30 ans
quarante salariés 300 couverts par jour
près de 5 millions de chiffre d'affaires
avant le confinement à salariés 5 à 10
commandes par jour 500 euros de chiffre
d'affaires par jour
on a besoin de garder le lien on a fait
ce choix parce qu'on veut garder le lien
et de nos clients on a besoin de nos
clients pour continuer à garder le moral
on est une maison qui n'a plus de dettes
donc on a repris la dette ça nous permet
de pouvoir peut-être passer cette crise
plus facilement que ceux qui sont plus
jeunes et qui ont beaucoup de dettes
mais tous les restaurants aujourd'hui
sont en danger
on va sur la boutique en ligne et on
fait sa commande en ligne et on choisit
soit une livraison soit un click and
collect on a gardé tous les standards de
notre carte ce qui plaît à nos clients
et c'est une classique qui plaisent le
foie gras de ried wollerau mme steak et
moi le chocolat le produit de saison du
moment c'est la coquille saint-jacques
de la baie de seine le petit truc c'est
la saisir sur une poêle antiadhésive
avec un filet d'huile d'olive vierge et
l'associer avec une sauce aux fruits de
la passion
patrick mignola petit fils de
restaurateur ça va vous parler comme ça
un témoignage comme celui ci vous
imaginez peut-être votre grand père à sa
place c'est terrible c'est cruel pour un
restaurateur vous lisiez vous même c'est
tellement sympa de faire la cuisine et
puis là tout s'effondre il faut
s'arrêter
c'est terrible c'est on est en train de
vivre une période complètement inédite
voilà en affrontant plusieurs crises à
la fois je regroupe allemand on a bien
fait au delà des au delà des
appartenances politiques d'aider ces
gens là parce que c'est parce que c'est
des passionnés parce que c'est des bons
parce que c'est des gens qu'on investit
jeu sûr que monsieur moussa il aurait pu
faire plein d'autres choses dans la vie
que restaurateur il fait ça aussi parce
que c'est le savent a serré les aides
que vous avez mise en place tous
pourront s'en sortir à lens se confinant
mois est ce qu'on me dit en tout cas sur
le terrain c'est que ça a permis dans le
premier confinement clairement de
de passer l'obstacle sinon c'était
impossible dire je le vois de l'autre
côté des alpes en italie il ya
énormément de restaurants confirmés qui
ont fermé corps et même du mal à
redémarrer aujourd'hui nous ça a permis
de maintenir la structure
après comme à chaque fois qu'on prend
des mesures on peut avoir quelques
angles morts et les angles le mans c'est
effectivement ce qui sont installés dans
les semaines qui ont précédé le
confinement donc là c'est terrible parce
que le modèle économique peut pas
tourner le business plan peut pas être
réalisée il n'y a pas de fonds de
commerce c'est difficile d'aller trouver
justement même des prêts garantis par
l'état alors qu'il n'y a pas encore un
bilan qui a été réalisée donc là on va
essayer de 2,2 d'ajuster encore le la
législation pour ces personnes-là
dans certaines villes comme si on doit
faire un effort
on doit faire un effort très particulier
où là on n'est plus en train de discuter
de dette parce qu'au fond ça coûtera
plus cher que des restaurants comme sa
ferme
ça coûtera plus cher demain que de les
soutenir aujourd'hui donc il faut faire
faire cet effort un peu un peu sur
humain est objectivement plus beaucoup
d'entre eux ont su rebondir après le
confinement en travaillant beaucoup mais
il mais il est évident de toute façon il
ya un métier où on peut pas rattraper
les choses dans le btp vous rattraper
les chantiers que vous avez pas fait ce
qu'ils sont toujours là mais un repas
non pris les gens viendront pas aux
quatre repas le lendemain
circonscription vous avez vu des
restaurants fermés dans les villes de la
circonscription
non non on en a eu très peu
certains certains ont fermé un de leur
restaurant bar anglais on a certains
restaurateurs qui avait deux ou trois
restos ils ont maintenu les plus petits
mais mais ce qui était un peu plus grand
ou un peu plus chic voilà je n'avais pas
retrouvé de clientèle tout de suite donc
donc ils ont réduit la voilure
ils ont remplacé sa part du retrait
commandes ça fait plutôt que je commande
je passe je viens à récupérer vous le
faites vous ici à l'assemblée par
exemple vous allez dans les restaurants
alentours passez commande et puis hop
vous l'emportez j'ai pas le temps de le
faire donc je prends le sac où il ya un
petit repas de l'assemblée qui est fait
et cela présente un inconvénient c'est
que c'est quand même moins bon donc dans
les restos autour bon tant mieux on
économise l'argent public c'est quand
même pas terrible ça a annoncé un
avantage c'est que je peux je peux
déjeuner avec mes copains en visio en
fait voilà hier à midi encore voilà j'ai
dû chuter tout seul dans mon bureau et
j'ai appelé un copain on a déjeuné
ensemble comme ça en visio mais bon je
ne pensais pas que ça m'arriverait un
jour dans ma vie sur des par exemple et
les ibériques les frichtis fin tout
s'est tu fais façon de consommer il ya
cent ans ferme en leur faisant vous vous
donnez le à les grandes villes mais
d'aller non non non non on a très peu
ils ont peu à voir on peut avoir de la
livraison
on a des entreprises de click and
collect j'étais des traiteurs qui se
sont installés moi j'en ai à deux pas de
ma permanence qui est très bien on peut
aller chercher mais là bas on vient sur
place en récupère le les plats après non
le reste on n'a pas encore de
numérisation ça ne me choque guère voilà
parce qu'elles permettent de vendre un
peu plus je trouve que je trouve ça
c'est bien beau mais tant mieux si ça
peut participer à leur santé économique
à tout dire je trouve ça un peu bête
quand on est chez soi ne pas faire 50 m
100 m à pied pour aller chercher on vous
dit au restaurant du coin puis sur
amazon à acheter vos produits
il faut aller sur internet mais on n'est
pas obligé de passer par le distributeur
amazon 80% du commerce d'ailleurs en
ligne en france assuré par amazon c'est
exactement
utiliser ça l'autre jour à l'assemblée
exactement en fait on se fait on se fait
toute une histoire sur amazon
parce que tout d'un coup les
supermarchés certains d'entre eux enfin
c'est surtout le sait surtout michel
edouard leclerc qui fait polémique
autour de sa ont voulu nous expliquer
les décisions qu'on avait pris
finalement de bénéficier qu'à amazon
mais c'était pour se protéger lui-même
dans ses propres intérêts donc tout ça
pas de sens il ya la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui il doit y avoir du commerce
qui se numérise il ya des communes
aujourd'hui qu'ils investissent qui
créent des applis pour faire des
vitrines virtuelles que ce soit pour
dire basta de forme que ce soit pour ça
vous le c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
invente le au fond amazon a juste
inventé l'idée la plus courte du monde
s'est distribué ce que font les autres
et ben moi je préfère qu'on aille
acheter directement à ce qu'ils avaient
vu le débat à l'assemblée vous avez vu
comment ça se passe les petits commerces
qui ont fermé l'opposition d'hier
finalement il n'y a pas plus de risque
d'aller être d'aller se contaminer dans
un petit commerce que dans une grande
surface
ils sont peut-être pas tout à fait tort
mais c'est parfaitement exact
c'est d'ailleurs la question c'est pas
que quand vous allez dans une grande
surface vous êtes protégé c'est que vous
avez des risques dans une grande surface
et la question c'est la multiplication
des risques c'est à dire que plus vous
avez de rayons ouverts en grande surface
plus vous pouvez vous contaminer
lorsque vous allez dans un commerce vous
avez un risque aussi parce que en fait
c'est pas dans le petit commerce que
vous contaminer c'est parce que j'en ai
un récent des de chez vous vous allez
prendre votre voiture au parking vous
allez dans la rue vous faites la queue
dans la file d'attenté est donc vous
multipliez les interactions sociales
donc l'opposition au fond dans l'absolu
a raison de dire que après tout c'est
pas plus dangereux à l'intérieur d'un
petit commerce que sur son canapé mais
tant qu'on n'a pas inventé la
téléportation pour passer directement du
canapé à l'intérieur du petit commerce
il ya un risque de propagation le temps
guérit alors la trique mis là où vous
l'avez dit vous avez quatre enfants ils
sont grands et petits
noël est en ligne de mire comment va se
passer ce noël d'un point de vue festif
mais aussi d'un point de vue commerçants
commercial alors des courses comment à
noël bien des électriques de votre
dernier vous allez acheter ou alors
d'abord pour mon dernier ce n'est pas
c'est le père noël qui achètent les
bardes en train électrique
s'ils les commandes et ce sera
probablement plutôt une commande de lego
ninjago 2 ou 2 playmobil moi je suis sûr
que le père noël sera en capacité à la
réouverture des magasins de jouets ou en
allant faire du retrait commandes dans
les magasins avec des masques ouais
voilà et on en fera il ya aix-les-bains
formidable magasin de jouets il y en a
il y en a plusieurs autres plutôt en
moyenne surface à chambéry et on le fera
en faisant du retrait commandes sur
rendez vous c'est comme ça qu'on a
essayé qu'on essaiera d'organiser les
choses on va sauver un point devant ces
convois y échapper et les questions
finement total oui je crois donc on ira
moi je crois parce que je sais que je
constate dans ce conflit sur le terrain
alors c'est vrai que en savoie on était
quasiment pas touché lors du premier
confinement il a été énormément dans le
deuxième on a eu dix fois plus
d'hospitalisations en dix jours donc là
de tout le monde est à ces saisies moi
je constate beaucoup de discipline ça
veut dire que on adhère d'entrée de la
discipline il ya de la solidarité déjà
implique plutôt bien les règles et
paradoxalement je pense que les français
comprennent beaucoup mieux que les
politiques qui font exprès de pas
comprendre parfois comment on organisait
le confinement allez on va passer à la
troisième partie de cette émission et on
va parler du dessous des plats
fabriqué en france 1 c'est un logo qui
couple est un petit drapeau tricolore
fleury de sur de nombreux plats
transformez vous avez dû le voir vous
qui aimez les supermarchés pourtant
cette signalétique hd piège sur la
réelle provenance des produits concernés
alors acheter 100% français n'est donc
pas aussi simple que ça la preuve avec
cette enquête fouillée sur la
prolifération des logos c'est une
enquête des mairies et me bleu blanc
rouge dans les rayons de supermarchés le
made in france fait vendre à côté de ces
drapeaux tricolores de nombreuses
mentions cuisine et fabriqués ou encore
transformer en france cette signalétique
rassure le consommateur mais n'est pas
toujours très clair c'est vrai que des
fois on a des surprises on sait marquer
fabrication française et vous regardez
dans les dents les explications il ya un
certains produits viennent de lui c'est
pas que je suis contraint il ya la ccc
français bon vin on en achète de temps
en temps et hop c'est meilleur un
affichage parfois trompeur mais tout à
fait légale une seule condition pour
apposer ses mentions la dernière
transformation substantielle du produit
doit être réalisée en france par exemple
du jambon fabriqués avec du porc élevé
en espagne
découper ou cuits dans nos usines peut
tout à fait être estampillé made in
france
et les exemples ne manquent pas d abu
traquer et dénoncer par l'eau angie
foodwatch on va se retrouver avec sur le
paquet chez panzani par exemple du
viande bovine française alors que dedans
on va retrouver du port qui vient de
quelque part en europe on ne sait pas
d'où on va trouver des drapeaux français
on va trouver des petites cartes de
france comme ici fabricant en france sur
cette moutarde
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'à moutarde
aujourd'hui lé principe bond produite au
canada c'est la législation européenne
qui règlement de cette pratique
elle joue l'ambiguïté elle autorise tout
en interdisant la tromperie
nous on considère que ce type de prod2
démarche marketing induisent en erreur
le consommateur et donc elle ne devrait
pas exister
aujourd'hui on devrait pas pouvoir faire
ça en fait on pourrait on fait croire
aux consommateurs que d'acheter un
produit 100% français alors qu'il ne
l'est pas cela ne concerne pas seulement
les géants de l'agroalimentaire
cette start up spécialisée dans les
produits bio et vegan
utilise aussi cette parade aujourd'hui
on s'engage pour tous les futurs
produits être uniquement nom du made in
france
donc cette pâte à tartiner la haine et
made in france des produits fabriqués
dans la drôme et en haute savoie
mais lorsque l'on regarde de plus près
la provenance de ces ingrédients bio est
elle plus exotiques
par exemple les noisettes de cette pâte
à tartiner sont directement importé
d'italie aujourd'hui pour s'y retrouver
dans le maquis des labels il y as
origine france garantie pour l'obtenir
50% du prix de revient du produit doit
être acquis en france matière première
main d'oeuvre loyer de lusine ou encore
facture d'électricité tout est pris en
compte mais le label peine à s'imposer
pour être sûr on peut toujours se fier à
l'appellation d'origine protégée
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée ou
encore l'indication géographique
protégée
patrick mignola sk par un peu tromperie
sur la marchandise avec les étiquettes
comme sa cuisiné ou fabriqués en france
s'il ya tromperie mais je pense que il
faut qu'on soit très pédagogique et
répétitif il faut dire et redire et
redire que madeinfrance une
réglementation qui est assez bien fait
justement avec origine france garantie
pour que les français sachent que c'est
bien origine france garantie qui
garantit que ces faits en france
j'exclus pas totalement la question du
transformer en france parce que le la
cuisine c'est des bons produits c'est un
bon tournemain voilà c'est aussi
important d'avoir bien élevé les cochons
que de savoir bien faire le tout six ans
mais du mauvais cochon pour bien
cuisiner en france ça reste un mauvais
plat et donc ça reste quelque chose
qu'il faut forcément indiqué et je
trouve que les labels ont assez bien
évolué sur les dernières années ce qui
nous manque
comme très souvent dans ce pays c'est la
notion de contrôle et d'applications
c'est à dire que parfois des personnes
sont à la limite de la légalité
les inscriptions aux produits et on ne
les sanctionne pas je pense que on a une
passion pour faire des lois dans ce pays
on sait pas bien les appliquer je me
suis toujours dit que vision sans
application égal à l'uci de contrôle du
sinaï davantage contrôler les produits
c'est ça c'est d'intervenir davantage
évidemment le de toute façon si on veut
défendre le les plats l'authenticité en
fait l'enjeu de tout ça c'est quoi c'est
le prix c'est avant tout le consommateur
et on est tous pareils va plutôt au
moins cher et donc si un arc et france
en plus sur l'étiquette et que c'est
moins cher
c'est formidable enfin si c'est moins
cher c'est que c'est que vous faites un
peu roulé au passage en france il ya une
évidente france a fait et c'est bien
pour ça on fait ça finit de vous
convaincre d'acheter des produits pas
chers d'apple
je pense que le vrai enjeu comme le
comme le dit souvent mon copain richard
ramos le sait une éducation et c'est une
éducation à l'arbitrage budgétaire de
temps en temps il vaut mieux se dire
qu'on achète une vraie bonne viande
d'origine france plutôt que vouloir
absolument bouffer de la viande à tous
les repas ce qui est parfaitement
inutile pour l'équilibré même pour le
développement des enfants et en fait on
n'a pas encore cette culture là qu'il
faut on est persuadé français est
forcément plus cher le évidemment mais
évidemment parce que aujourd'hui enfin
les gens font pas ça pour rien pourquoi
les industriels vont chercher du port
qui est fait en pologne
gpb parce que de ceux qui élèvent les
ports en pologne sont payés 4 à 6 fois
moins que en france voilà c'est une
sorte de délocalisation qui abîment les
choses et franchement on a besoin de
soutenir nos fils et limiter les mandats
on doit mieux on doit mieux manger oui
mais et puis après certains peuvent
faire le choix et c'est dur vous avez
envie de manger de la viande tous les
jours donc vous acheter de la viande n'a
pas cher bon bah il verra le sont elles
sont gonflées d'eau elles sont
fabriquées par d'autres bons mais très
bien c'est votre choix mais moi je pense
qu'il faut inciter à partir du plus
jeune âge à manger et à boire
meyer - souvent témoins souvent
un trèfle prenez une bonne bouteille de
vin qui est fabriqué en france qui peut
coûter 17 ou 18 euros à l'achat
ça fait déjà une belle bouteille de vin
il vaut quand même mieux avoir une
bouteille de vin par semaine que
s'acheter des espèces de des espèces de
briques de vin dégueulasse qui ont été
fabriqués dans je ne sais quel pays
voilà mais on n'est pas en confiance de
la tromperie pas ce que vous dites vous
même
achetez vous avez répondu à brigitte
acheter français c'est plus cher donc
quand on achète fabriquer français on se
disait c'est normal que ce soit plus
cher or ce n'est pas des produits
français et le double jeu de la
législation européenne aussi qui luttent
contre la tromperie mais qui autorise ce
genre d'étiquetage oui mais mais parce
que va faire le ménage mais parce que
tout est dans l'application en fête est
pour quand une loi est mal appliquée
faut pas faire une autre loi faut
appliquer la loi
ça veut dire quoi dans ce cas ça veut
dire une présence dgccrf qui va vérifier
sur le terrain que le le le consommateur
n'est pas trompé qui va regarder le camp
les combes où ils sont lissés au liban
sont légaux s'ils sont pas toujours
légaux à cela quand ce que notre
reporter a filmé ils sont mais t es
quand vous mettez là il n'y a pas de
contrôle affaire c'est que c'est
consubstantiel au logo là quand vous
mettez de transformer en france vous
êtes dans la légalité dans le fabriqué
en france
en fait c'est un label qui n'existe pas
soit vous êtes made in france
et ça c'est très réglementé soit vous
êtes transformés en france voire
transformées dans la région soit vous
êtes origine france garantie
et donc quand quelqu'un mais fabriqué en
france très concrètement sur un produit
en fait il s'est inventé un logo bien
cesser c'est une amie le
bleu-blanc-rouge sur le bulletin de vote
alors qu est sanctionné hélas hélas il
peut y avoir sanction donc en fait
souvent c'est une affaire d'application
il faut qu'on soit en de beaucoup plus
présent en application sur dur aussi
parce que ma nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs ils sont pas toujours bien
rémunérés que les produits made in
france sont plus chers est-ce que c'est
pas un peu les limites de la loi et
ghanim aussi est ce que cette loi elle a
tenu finalement toutes ces promesses
n'ont pas suffisamment parce que c'est
parce qu'au fond on s'est intéressé dans
le lot et galim je pense à beaucoup de a
beaucoup de sujets
conex est complètement détourné la loi
de son objet en fait le les hypermarchés
en ont rêvé et les parlementaires sont
arrivés à le faire
qu est ce qui ressort de la loi et galim
dans l'opinion publique
le glyphosate parce qu on s'écharpe et
tu as question des niveaux de questions
importantes avec des évolutions
techniques technologiques qu'il faut
conduire le plus rapidement possible
fort bien non oubliez ce que c'est que
la loi veil légalisant pas de savoir si
oui ou non en fait on va supprimer le
glyphosate en 18 mois ou en 24 c est ce
que les éleveurs agriculteurs sera mieux
rémunéré exactement c'est dans la chaîne
de valeur comme dans tout système
économique entre celui qui produit celui
qui distribue celui qui consomme de la
fourche à la fourchette
comment on répartit mieux donc la valeur
ajoutée légiférer donc elle est là pour
le coup on va être obligé de re
légiférer et s'il ressort quelque chose
de ces crises c'est probablement que on
n'a retrouvé l'idée qu'on est assez
interdépendants on est dépendants les
uns des autres et donc je suis pas naïve
sur le fait que chacun essaye de gagner
sa vie et que la grande distribution
évidemment voudra continuer de gagner la
sienne mais mais on s'est probablement
rendu compte qu'il ya besoin de
rééquilibrage entre les acteurs la
question du partage de la valeur et la
partage entre le capital et le travail
dans toutes les entreprises
mais entre tous les acteurs d'une chaîne
industrielle ou agroalimentaires c'est
une question vous le verrez moi j'en ai
la conviction qui va monter très fort
dans l'année qu'il allait il nous reste
quelques instants on va passer au péché
mignon
alors j'en suis sûr qu'ils figuraient la
carte du restaurant de votre grand-père
exactement parce que ça c'est intemporel
années quarante années 2020 mais sait on
adore les yeux la neige alors c'est donc
ça c'est régressif c'est le goût de
l'enfance complètement si ça c'est ma
madeleine de proust à moi ça ressemblait
à ça visuellement là on a donc des oeufs
à la neige façon gâteau non parce que je
voyais en fait j'aime pas quand il ya du
caramel dessus alors pourquoi parce que
j'aime la rencontre du
ou de ceux de ce nuage de blancs d'oeufs
frais avec rem la crème anglaise
d'accord ça le et le petit côté croquant
du car vous avez passé que le caramel
mais après vous re sucré ah oui et voilà
donc si au fond si vous rajoutez du
sucre une crème anglaise qui l'est déjà
suffisamment
voilà je ne sais pas forcément être au
dessus c'est pas forcément bon c'est
voulais pas le goûter avec nous si si si
je vais le goûter si j'ai le droit
d'enlever le match mais vous avez deux
mois par mission pour le dessert mais
vous avez dit il ressemble pas à celui
de mon grand père pourquoi lorsque le
blanc n'était pas parce qu'elle a même
pas sont visuellement parce qu'ils aient
vraiment comme des oeufs c'est à dire
qu'en fait dernier dit il monte ses
blancs et ils arrivaient en fait à
l'aller fabriqués dans le dans le plat
le plat enfin la cuve d'eau bouillante
dire de telle sorte qu' il soit vraiment
elle comme un offres soient vraiment
voilà commun comme au blond voilà bien
au blé et en est un comme ça on avait en
avait deux ou trois dans le dans le plat
et c'était c'était juste un retour au
passage la petite astuce à son
grand-père la faisait cuire dans l'eau
bouillante
non pas dans le lait et c'est mieux
parce que logo à 100° et vous pouvez
davantage durcir vogler en neige alors
que le lait bout à 90 degrés donc c'est
une petite astuce voilà juste que votre
grand père connaissait bien entendu
c'est comme ça qu'on fait mieux les yeux
pochés kampala exactement alors pendant
le confinement s'est pas toujours
toujours facile de voir la vie en rose
les appartements sont parfois exigus
on a le droit de sortir qu'une heure par
jour alors on doit décider bien de vous
redonner un peu la banane alors ça ça
vous redonne sûrement un peu la banane
déjà ce dessert la batterie que monsieur
très très bon mais sinon c'était quoi
ces petits moments de grâce que vous
avez eue pendant le premier confinement
ou que vous avez encore aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui finalement vous re vous
fait plaisir
alors j'ai vécu un confinement un peu un
peu singulier puisque je faisais partie
des 15 parlementaires qui devait quand
même venir toutes les semaines à
l'assemblée pour pouvoir le faire vivre
le parlement en portant les voies du
groupe que je préside mais j'ai passé un
peu plus de temps à la maison
donc j'ai pu un passé un peu plus de
temps avec mon petit dernier
parce que comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure un mois j'avais arrêté la
politique dans la vie c'était
précisément au moment où on a décidé de
faire un bébé et puis et puis finalement
pas de chance enfin pas de chance il
faut prendre toutes les chances comme
elles viennent il ya il est né au moment
où je repartais dans une carrière
politique et où je suis devenu député
donc le temps que je peux passer avec
lui c'est un temps formidable des échecs
peut-être non ben oui c'est ça alors les
hautmontois ciom on est passé un peu de
temps ensemble
il est grand car n'attire le franchement
ce qu'il fait le plus rire c'est de
mettre son père en difficulté quand il
s'agit de monter des lego mais il il est
passionné par les échecs gelé beaucoup
d'enfants commencé chez vous alors ça se
trouve très exactement là on devait être
à amboise a puisque je l'avais amené en
boîte voir le lit mini châteaux pour que
quand on découvre tous les petits
châteaux de du val de loire
et puis là il y avait un jeu d'échecs
géant et donc on a apprécié plâtre ont
appris le métier droit je suis jamais le
droit de tout ça avec mes enfants j'ai
pas voix au chapitre
et sinon vous avez pu lire un petit pot
c'est quoi votre livre votre livre
préféré ou votre pipe du confinement le
c'est légal au j'ai fait beaucoup de
beaucoup de mecs galopant dans le
confinement cdg passer l'année quasiment
sur le sur les biographies les récits
historiques de max gallo monomaniaque
que tu es formidable oui oui oui il ya
des sortes de il ya des périodes comme
ça c'est j'avais une année spahic à la
ségalot je l'avais que et il y avait
chez galloo il y en a qui est absolument
formidable d'ailleurs des tout derniers
qu'il est écrit c'est son autobiographie
celle oublier la rue du diable et qui
décrit qui décrit comment d'une famille
modeste d'un ouvrier métallo là il est
monté au sommet de l'état et à
l'académie française
et voilà c'était des très belles
histoires aussi vous avez plus lus par
le confinement parce que certains disent
on n'a pas publié ont été encombrées
cette angoisse anxiogène où j'arrivais
pas à plonger dans un livre ce n'est pas
votre cas
non enfin dans la journée je disais ça
peut passer par le confinement il y
avait il fait beaucoup de choses à gérer
ne devoir c'était plutôt d'être au
contact avec les acteurs économiques et
sociaux mémo jolie tous les soirs avant
de m'endormir
on n'est jamais très loin de la
politique la chance de tourner dans les
séries que vous aimez puisque je crois
que c'est baron noir votre série
préférée
oui c'est ce que j'ai adoré barreau moi
je trouve ça formidable mais au fond
j'ai avec le recul vous en meurent année
c'est pire que ça c'est qu'en fait
finalement il avait assez peu
d'imagination par rapport à ce qu'on vit
liste qui arrive quasiment après les
dernières séries effectivement mais
après les faits main faire des
cauchemars marée noire et les retraites
la crise sanitaire la crise économique
et sociale la crise sécuritaire
ce que j'ai vécu dans ce premier mandat
de parlementaire
il me reste l'invasion des sauterelles
ou celle des extraterrestres voilà donc
il faut prendre les choses avec recul et
10 ans avec beaucoup d'eux et que plus
de sérénité et de solidité possible mais
mais je trouvais ce scénario parfois
invraisemblables et finalement la
réalité de la largement dépassé à la
presse qu'elle avait rattrapé en tout
cas on va écouter quelque chose
maintenant si vous voulez bien
attention au prénom parce qu'il ya deux
frigos thiais oui c'est gautier c'est le
violoncelliste gautier capuçon
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas reconnu est
ce que d'ailleurs connaît la musique
[Musique]
plus fort en fromage qu'en musique la
bonne et moi je je suis un mélomanes
amateurs
j'aime entendre de la musique classique
mais j'ai eu de la chance d'ailleurs de
côtoyer les frères capuçon parce que ils
sont tout simplement originaire de la
colombie c'est vrai dont j'étais dont
j'étais maire la ravoire la petite
commune dont vous parlez ouais et
j'étais en classe avec leurs grandes
soeurs cessé de deux garçons qui ont un
talent absolument formidable c'est vrai
que j'ai une préférence pour le pôle
violoncelle c'est des artistes qui sont
très occupés qu'ils sont très sollicités
mais qui en plus savent savent d'où ils
viennent essaye de rendre
merci merci patrick mignola d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et on peut les
eaux pour les écouter aussi sur un temps
de tout bien sûr les retrouver sur
internet on va remercier aussi le
restaurant chez françoise qui nous a
fourni comme chaque semaine tous ses
plats merci jean pierre merci alors à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis et puis
on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table
[Musique]